فيديو عن حركة المرور في أعقاب
الهجوم الإرهابي في كابول أو تشويش ذلك
الفيديو لأنه مثير للاشمئزاز
يمكنك رؤية صف من الجثث أصيب بعضها
بين المواطنين ، وهناك آخرون ناجون ومارة
يبحثون عن أي شخص يستطيعون
يمكنه مساعدتي الآن  منتج سي إن إن تيم
ليستر الذي كان ينقل تفاصيل على نطاق واسع
من أه كابول
أم تيم ماذا تفعل ماذا نعرف
الآن أننا لم نكن نعرف منذ ساعة
أندرسون أعتقد أن أهم
شيء نعرفه هو أن هذا كان معقدًا
يتناسب مع
أسلوب عمل Isis K من نواحٍ عديدة ، وكان لديهم
الدافع للقيام بذلك ، وكان لديهم بالتأكيد
القدرة على القيام بذلك ، وكان ذلك
نموذجيًا لدراجتهم النارية Randy ، إنه
حشد مدني كبير ثابت يمكن
بسهولة الوصول إليه في الأشهر الأربعة الأولى  من
هذا العام وحده وفقًا لبعثة الأمم المتحدة في
أفغانستان ، فقد نفذوا
77 هجومًا في جميع أنحاء أفغانستان بشكل رئيسي
في التهويدة وكابول لديهم
خلايا نائمة في كابول والتي تلاحق
التجمعات المدنية الكبرى في كثير من الأحيان
تستهدف مساجد السيخ الشاهقة على سبيل المثال.
قادرين على معرفة ما
يفعلونه وأرادوا أيضًا أن
يُظهروا لطالبان أنهم مرتدون
في نظرهم وأن الصفقة التي
وضعوها في غرف الفنادق في قطر كانت
في الأساس تسليم الإسلام
للأمريكيين لذلك لم يكونوا كذلك  مهمة أه
إيزيس ك وقد تم
استكمالهم أيضًا بأكثر من 100 ربما
عدة مئات من سجناء داعش الذين
فروا في طالبان المتقدمة عبر
أفغانستان وخاصة من سجنين
بالقرب من كابول حيث احتجزوا في
طعامهم